[Music]
alright hey everybody what's going on
welcome to the live KOCO cam this is the
next 24 hours we're going to be
streaming live from our coding offices
from this camera you're seeing right
here this is all alive so crazy things
might happen and I guess just bear with
us there's going to be some down time
there's gonna be some fun time there's
going to be some scary time hopefully
not too much scary time but you can
follow all the action at on our website
team koco.com
slash live you can also follow it at
youtube.com slash team Coco and
facebook.com slash team Coco if you'd
like to tweet about this event which we
hope you'll be tweeting about this event
please use the hashtag live Coco can you
all you kids know how to do that so yeah
that's basically it we'll be checking
back in with you throughout this 24
hours and it's going to be a lot of fun
so keep your eyes peeled and stay tuned
as for right now we'd like to start you
off with little 80s aerobics put your
bets down
[Music]
five six seven to go right back left
forward right back left for me personal
ex back to right forward and left back
right for right shoulder up shoulder up
right left right left shoulder rotate
back left right left right left right
left up for it right left right left
right left right left
no beach
reach reach reach reach and to the side
start
we've reached whoops push push push
now squat and up squat up squat up squat
end up inside side side side side side
side side
[Music]
[Music]
you